so we had this absolutely horrific
parkland Florida mass school shooting
took nearly 20 lives and in the wake of
that the NRA continues to be out there
talking about more guns in school and
more guns in more places and maybe
hopefully I would say this time
Americans are so sick of this disgusting
gone lob gun lobby that works solely for
the gun makers and not for the people
and not for gun safety but merely to
sell as many guns as possible hopefully
this time the counter movement will
actually have an effect and at least
early on it appears that some of the
calls for boycotts are starting to work
Delta Airlines got a lot of attention
for saying that they are going to be
ending their partnership with the
National Rifle Association where people
going to the NRA conference get
discounts on flights can you imagine
anything more disgusting but there's
actually more companies other than just
Delta that are bailing and I'm gonna
tell you about a couple of them first
here is Delta's announcement on Twitter
where Delta said Delta is reaching out
to the NRA to let them know we will be
ending their contract for discounted
rates through our group travel program
we will be requesting that the NRA
remove our information from their
website now I've said before I've tended
not to fly Delta in general mostly
because it's not that convenient when
you live in Boston but also because
they're pretty anti-union but lots of
airlines are anti-union and this is a
good thing and at least this decision is
something that the Delta should be
commended for United Airlines which I
use more often than Delta is also
bailing tweeting United is notifying the
NRA that we will no longer offer a
discounted rate to their annual meeting
and we are asking that the NRA remove
our information from their website and
American Airlines which I fly most often
living in Boston saying in no uncertain
terms that they have no partnership with
the NRA to clarify questions we have
received today they tweeted American
does not offer discounted group travel
rates to the NRA it's not just Airlines
to car rental companies jumping on board
Hertz saying that they have notified the
NRA that they are ending
their car discount program with Hertz
and Alamo Car Rental saying we ended the
program effective March 26th it's not
just Airlines and car rental companies
it is also hotels Wyndham hotels
tweeting - a woman named Elaine who
inquired please no Wyndham is no longer
affiliated with the NRA the First
National Bank of Omaha of which I am a
customer also tweeting customer feedback
has caused us to review our relationship
with the NRA as a result First National
Bank of Omaha will not renew its
contract with the National Rifle
Association to issue the NRA Visa card
that's gonna be a big hit right the gun
that's really like having their NRA
credit card that they can use everywhere
this is good okay these public shame
campaigns are very effective it was
effective against Breitbart we covered
that over the last year and a half and
this happened because people people like
you went online
they found a list of the partnerships
that different companies have with the
NRA and they started tweeting at those
brands saying drop the association with
the NRA now there's a counter-argument
here right which is David listen it's
good that the partnerships are ending
but it's not because of shame that these
corporations are ending their NRA
partnerships its loss of revenue that
they are worried about and I have two
thoughts on that number one I don't know
if that's true right because when you do
this the pro-gun crowd is now saying
well we're gonna counter boycott Delta
and we're gonna counter boycott Windham
hotels and United Airlines and whoever
else so I don't know that these brands
can necessarily calculate whether this
is going to be a net financial gain or
loss for them but I would take it a step
further either way ending these
partnerships is good if it's the threat
of loss of revenue rather than the
public shame that gets companies like
herds and Alamo and American and United
to say we don't have partnerships with
the NRA I'll still take it right I still
think it's good and that we should be
happy that that's going on and I was
actually thinking about
different sort of boycott campaigns
recently the campaign from the left
against the NRA has already been way
more successful than the right-wing
campaign against the NFL and associated
companies over allowing players to kneel
during the national anthem and I was
thinking about how the right-wing
boycotts often failed the NFL stuff
really hasn't had much of an impact they
wanted to boycott the Hamilton Broadway
play when was it Pat that pence was
booed it was a very important mission
during the transition right it was
before the inauguration I think and then
right-wingers said boycott Hamilton
record Hamilton attendance continues and
and ticket prices are through the roof
they wanted to boycott the newest Star
Wars movie not well not the newest
actual Star Wars movie remember rogue
one that was out there because they
right-wingers believed it was indirectly
criticizing the Trump administration
that failed the movie did really really
well so we do have some silver linings
here that some of the good boycotts seem
to be working and some of the bogus
right whip right wing boycotts seem to
be failing it's hard to say at this
point whether or not the NRA boycotts
gonna succeed or fail but what's clear
is that the NRA definitely miscalculated
if after all these shootings that came
out with the most simple gun reform
measures and we're in support of basic
things like background checks I don't
think these companies would have
boycotted them probably not and I think
part of that was timing right because
the NRA is a staple at CPAC and Wayne
LaPierre spoke it was at CPAC over the
weekend that if that Wayne LaPierre
spoke and oftentimes the move by the NRA
is to not even be visible publicly for a
while after each shooting and I don't
know if it's weeks or months or whatever
but when I saw Wayne LaPierre speaking
at CPAC it just felt too soon their move
is disappear evaporate like they don't
exist for a little bit and then come
back a little bit later but they are
front and center and that accident
that's actually what I want to talk
about next which is how prominent NRA
advertising has been since this shooting
today's program is sponsored in part by
movement watches you've heard me talk
about movement watches before I have
been wearing movement watches for
a long time the company has grown like
crazy they've now sold almost 2 million
watches in a hundred and 60 countries
and they continue to sort of go forward
with the idea that it shouldn't be
really expensive to get a nice-looking
watch and I don't know if you've checked
out their website lately they've doubled
the number of watch Styles and are still
expanding I get compliments on my
movement watch everywhere I go people
look at it I can tell I'm trying to talk
to them they're distracted by the watch
and then they say where'd you get that
watch and usually people are shocked
that you're not required to spend four
to five hundred dollars like you would
at a department store for a watch of
this style and quality they start at
just 95 bucks because they sell direct
to consumer you can get 15% off today
with free shipping and free returns if
you go to MVM t-dot-com forward slash
Pakman check out why they keep growing
check out the growing collection at MVM
t.com /p a que ma n